[Musique]
pénurie de personnel des enseignants
débordés et à bout de souffle des
infrastructures vieillissantes parfois
vétustes le système d'éducation Québec
n'a pas la vie facile et les solutions
pour lui redonner de la vigueur semble
difficile à imposer c'est le nouveau
ministre Bernard drinville qui a demandé
de remettre le réseau sur les rails il a
présenté ses 7 priorités jeudi admettant
que les détails de plusieurs
propositions restaient encore à venir je
l'ai rencontré à Laval Bernard Rainville
ministre de l'Éducation du Québec
bonjour merci d'être avec nous merci de
vous être déplacé jusqu'à Laval un
plaisir bon 100 jours ça fait un peu
plus de 100 jours 100 jours 100 jours
vous avez commencé votre mandat vous
avez dit jeudi lors de votre première
conférence de presse j'ai visité un
paquet d'école j'ai parlé avec des
enseignants j'ai parlé avec du personnel
des étudiants aussi qu'est-ce vous a de
tout ce que vous avez vu entendu
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus frappé
la composition de la classe
le fait que
il y a de plus en plus d'élèves a besoin
particulier et que les besoins sont de
plus en plus grands et ça ça a un impact
sur le travail des enseignants
enseignants sur le personnel ça un
impact aussi sur le climat dans la
classe et donc ces enfants-là a besoin
particulier donc
difficulté d'adaptation difficulté
d'apprentissage dans certains cas ils
sont TSA donc troubles du spectre de
l'autisme dans d'autres cas anxiété
tout ça fait en sorte que la classe
n'est plus ce qu'elle était et donc les
enseignants ont besoin d'aide vous avez
évoqué l'idée d'utiliser des du
personnel des services de garde par
exemple on va appuyer mais vous venez de
parler de
d'étudiants d'élèves qui ont des grands
besoins oui je suis en train de dire que
ils n'ont pas leur place dans la classe
régulière je suis en train de dire que
parce qu'ils ont des grands besoins il
faut s'en occuper
la garderie qui a pas nécessairement les
la formation les outils pour gérer ça
comment est-ce que va contribuer à ce
contexte
si vous en parlez aux enseignants c'est
ce que j'ai fait dans ma tournée et puis
j'ai parlé aux éducatrices également ils
vont donner des exemples très très
concrets mettons un élève se désorganise
actuellement un élève qui mettons qui
refuse de suivre la consigne qui se lève
debout dans la dans la classe ou qui
pour une raison pour une autre
une réaction
émotive mettons mais là la classe doit
s'arrêter actuellement le faux que
l'enseignante s'occupe de cet élève là
s'il y avait un deuxième adulte une
deuxième adulte dans la classe cette
personne-là pourrait s'en occuper et les
éducatrices suivants connaissent les
enfants parce que elles sont au service
de garde le matin le midi est en fin de
journée et donc dans certains cas à tout
le moins elles ont déjà eu un contact
avec l'enfant donc ce lien là est déjà
créé et donc ça peut contribuer à
l'apaiser il y a un lien ça peut aider
est-ce que c'est une solution temporaire
non je souhaite que ce soit une solution
permanente
une formation on va prendre des
spécialistes un moment donné un système
là c'est à dire il faudra voir une fois
que les éducatrices seront dans les
salles de classe est-ce que dans
certains cas il pourrait y avoir une
formation d'appoint
on verra ok c'est comme ça que vous
l'imaginez pas pas en disant on va
embaucher on va utiliser les ressources
et ressources là en attendant d'avoir
des éducatrices spécialisées qui
viennent se joindre au mix moi je
souhaite que les éducatrices en service
de garde je souhaite que ça devienne une
solution permanente mais ça veut pas
dire que c'est la seule solution il y a
déjà des éducatrices en éducation des
tes techniciens en éducation spécialisée
qui sont déjà dans les classes pas tout
le temps à temps plein mais qui sont
dans les classes qui vont se promener
mettons d'une classe à l'autre puis
évidemment ça remplacera pas les
professionnels comme les orthopédagogues
comme les psychoé éducatrices tout ça
mais c'est un ajout qui serait très
important l'intégration des élèves en
difficulté dans la classe normale ça
c'est est-ce que ça pourrait être remis
en question
dans le processus de réflexion que vous
avez entamé non le principe de
l'intégration on veut le conserver mais
on se rend compte que pour que ça
fonctionne il faut que les enseignants
aient de l'aide c'est pour ça que le les
aides à la classe comme ça qu'on les
appelle deviennent si importantes ça
veut pas dire Daniel que
que ça n'arrivera pas qu'un élève est
juste pas
peu juste pas rester dans une tasse
régulière et c'est pour ça que les
classes d'adaptation scolaire existe
c'est pour les cas plus difficile plus
exigeants plus lourd et là donc dans les
classes d'adaptation scolaire ce sont
des groupes plus petits et il y a même
des classes spéciales ça existe encore
les classes spéciales donc faut pas se
mettre la tête dans le sable dans
certains cas l'intégration d'un élève a
besoin particulier n'est pas possible
dans une classe régulière c'est pas
possible alors faut alors il faut le
faire je dirais avec jugement il faut
pas leur il faut pas en faire un dogme
vous avez évoqué la volonté de modifier
la formation universitaire qui mène à
l'enseignement c'est-à-dire
pour les pour les personnes qui ont déjà
un bac voilà certains ont parlé d'une
forme de nivellement par le bas pourquoi
pourquoi
des spécialistes en matière d'éducation
avant de mettre cette idée là de l'avant
et moi ce qu'on m'a dit c'est que une
formation de 30 crédits bien bien conçu
bien pensé et suffisante pour permettre
à un bachelier en français ou à une
bachelière en mathématiques ou quelqu'un
qui a un bac en histoire ou en
géographie peu importe avec une
formation d'appoint de 30 crédits cette
personne-là est-ce qu'il faut pour se
retrouver comme enseignante avec le
brevet d'enseignement dans une salle de
classe du primaire ou du secondaire
rappelez-vous Daniel que ça a déjà
existé ceux qui me disent ceux qui me
propose ce qui me disent la maîtrise
qualifiante actuellement le 60 crédit et
trop long trop lourd il me disent
rappelle-toi que ça a déjà existé un
certificat en pédagogie de 30 crédit
j'aimerais vous entendre sur la qualité
du français on en a abondamment parlé
cette semaine sans y avoir un énorme
problème de qualité du français des gens
qui graduent au niveau qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'on peut faire à court
terme pour tenter de ramener ça un
niveau acceptable alors je suis très
inquiet de ça
je suis très inquiet en fait de
l'état du français écrit et donc je suis
en réflexion sur les moyens qu'on va
prendre pour corriger cette situation là
mais chose certaine
la situation actuelle ne peut pas faire
par quoi je sais que vous êtes en
réflexion ça passe par quoi qu'est-ce
qui peut être fait à court terme devient
une solution c'est une bonne question je
veux pas je veux pas m'avancer parce que
je suis pas encore prêt à conclure
j'ai encore je suis encore en train de
réfléchir puis je suis encore en train
de d'aller chercher de l'information
pour être certain de prendre la bonne
décision
de précis là-dessus là est-ce que c'est
normal par exemple que un travail
qu'un enseignant soit limité dans le
nombre de points qui peut être retiré
d'un travail quand il y a des fautes de
français est-ce que ça ça pourrait être
une ça fait partie de mes réflexions de
la même façon que
un exercice dans le cours de français
devrait faire l'objet d'une correction
au niveau des fautes d'orthographe faute
de grammaire
maintenant est-ce que un exercice dans
le cours d'histoire
devrait aussi faire l'objet d'une
correction au niveau des fautes de
français des fautes de grand-mère des
fautes d'orthographe
moi je pense que oui moi je pense que
oui tu me remets un travail tu me remets
un travail alors là est-ce qu'il faut
toujours aller dans la sanction est-ce
qu'il faut toujours dire pourtant de
fautes enlève tant de points
c'est là qu'il faut réfléchir le avant
parce que là dépendamment du niveau où
on part si on commence à enlever des
points pour chaque faute d'orthographe
ou chaque pied à chaque 5 fautes ou
dispose dans certains cas d'après ce que
je lis d'après ce que j'entends on
pourrait se retrouver avec une note
pratiquement
donné il faut quand même prendre le
temps de réfléchir puis voir comment on
amène ça mais actuellement c'est pour ça
que je vous dis actuellement je suis
encore en train de prendre acte du
problème mais ce que j'entends puisque
je vois aussi parce que j'en ai vu dans
ma tournée des écoles c'est pas
rassurant au niveau du français écrit en
particulier merci beaucoup ça a été un
plaisir à la prochaine